مصر استعاده اكثر من 29 الف قطعه اثريه
لكن يبلغ عدد هذه القطعه خارج البلاد في
اقل تقدير طبقا لاحصاءات دقيقه مليون قطعه
يبقى الملف مفتوحا سواء لجهه استعاده
الاثار من المتاحف في الخارج او وقف
عمليات التهريب فخلال عام 2022 وحده تم
ضبط حواليه
3496 قطعه اثريه بالمنافذ المصريه قبل
خروجها من البلاد بطرق غير قانونيه من اهم
القطع الاثريه الفريده خارج مصر هي حجروا
رشيد حاليا في المتحف البريطاني في لندن
ايضا راس نفرتيتي التي تعرض في المتحف
المصري بالعاصمه الالمانيه برلين كذلك
تمثال وزير الملك خوفو ومهندس بناء الهرم
الاكبر يوجد حاليا هذا التمثال في المانيا
ايضا لوحه زودياك موجوده حاليا في متحف
لوفر بفرنسا وقطعه من ذقن ابو الهول وتعرض
في المتحف البريطاني يوجد في مصر خمسه
مسلات بينما في روما ووحدها ثماني مسلات
مصريه تشير الاحصاءات الى ان عدد المسلات
يصل الى مئه مثلث